>> Tucker: THERE HE IS.
CELEBRITIES
WERE QUICK TO GIVE THEIR OPINION
WERE QUICK TO GIVE THEIR OPINIO
OPINION.
CHELSEA HANDLER TWEETED THIS.
WE HAVE TO LET CANDIDATES THAT
ARE NOT FUNDED BY THE NRA.
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO ELECT
CANDIDATES WHO WOULD ALLOW KIDS
TO GO TO SCHOOL AND GET SHOT.
IT IS DISCUSSING HOW MAY TIMES
AS THIS HAPPENED AND REPLICANTS
DO NOTHING.
YOU WILL HAVE BLOOD ON YOUR
HANDS.
A LOT OF OTHER TWEETS IN THAT
SAME VEIN.
MARK STEYN SPECIALIZES IN
CELEBRITY TWEETS AND HE'S
COMPILING A BOOK ON THIS
SUBJECT, WE HOPE.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
>> GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
>> Tucker: WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
THE RESPONSE TO THIS?
>> AT A CERTAIN LEVEL, I
UNDERSTAND THESE IDIOTIC TWEETS
BECAUSE THE DEFINING ACT OF
THESE SCHOOL SHOOTINGS IS THE
ABSENCE OF MEANING.
IN A SENSE, WHEN YOU'RE DOING IT
FOR ALL, THAT'S EASIER TO
UNDERSTAND THAN THESE COMPLETELY
EMPTY, PURPOSELESS EVENTS WHERE
A GUY JUST KILLED A BUNCH OF
SCHOOL KIDS FOR NO REASON AT
ALL.
IN THAT VACUUM, WHERE WE SEARCH
FOR MEANING, PEOPLE POUR THEIR
LAMEST, DREARY USED TROPES.
TO BLAME IT ON THE NRA IS THE
DEFAULT POSITION AND THAT'S WHAT
THEY DO.
IT'S PRECISELY BECAUSE THERE WAS
AN ABSENCE OF MEANING OF THIS
EVENT.
THAT'S BECAUSE A GUY KILLED 17
PEOPLE FOR NO REASON WHATSOEVER
IN THEY DID NOTHING TO HIM.
THE REASONS FOR IT ARE DEEPER,
MORE COMPLEX AND IT BEHOOVES US
IN MEMORY OF THE DEAD TO
ACTUALLY TALK AND THINK
SERIOUSLY ABOUT IT.
>> Tucker: THAT'S A VERY DEEP
OBSERVATION ABOUT THE HOLLOWNESS
AND THE COURT OF THESE THINGS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
I KNOW YOU DON'T WANT TO
SPECULATE NO RESPONSIBLE PERSON
DOES, BUT YOU'VE WATCHED YEARS
OF THIS.
WHAT'S YOUR INSTINCTS ABOUT SOME
OF THE CAUSES OF IT?
>> FOR EXAMPLE, I THINK YOU
TALKED ABOUT SOCIAL ENTERPRISE
ASIAN AND THAT'S TRUE.
THE FACT IS, THE CONDEMNATION
AFFECT IS YOU CAN BE SOCIALLY
ENTIRELY DYSFUNCTIONAL AND
ACTUALLY HAVE WHAT SEEMS LIKE A
RICH AND REWARDING FANTASY LIFE
THROUGH TECHNOLOGY NOW.
IN THE LATE 19TH CENTURY IF YOU
WERE A MISERABLE SOCIAL LOSER,
YOU ARE BASICALLY ON YOUR OWN
KICKING THE CAN AROUND THE
BACKYARD PIER THERE IS NOTHING
ELSE TO DO.
NOW LIKE THIS GUY, YOU CAN GO ON
THE INTERNET, YOU CAN MAKE
THREATS, YOU CAN LEAD A
REWARDING LIFE COMMUNICATING
WITH SOME GUY IS ALL OVER THE
WORLD AND IN SOME SENSE, THAT
FANTASY LIFE IS MORE REAL FOR
PEOPLE THAN ACTUALLY GOING TO
THE SODA FOUNTAIN AND HAVING A
CHOCOLATE MALT WITH FRIENDS.
THAT'S VERY DISTURBING.
THE FACT THAT THE VOID IS NOW
IS GREAT PERIL AND THAT BECAUSE
IT SUGGESTS WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
MORE OF THESE KINDS OF PEOPLE IN
THE YEARS AHEAD.
>> Tucker: WE'VE NOT PAUSED